a CBS News investigation reveals that
our federal fund intended to protect
flood victims often benefits private
insurance companies instead the National
Flood Insurance Program run by FEMA is
25 billion dollars in debt in some years
up to two-thirds of the money that's
supposed to help flood victims goes to
private insurance companies and the
attorneys they hire to fight flood
claims CBS Evening News anchor Jeff Glor
is here with our CBS News investigation
Jeff good morning Nora good morning when
record floods hit Louisiana in 2016 a
hundred and fifty thousand people had
damage to their homes an estimated 15
billion dollars in damage two years
later many homeowners are still
struggling to rebuild and flooding the
same companies and lawyers that they
fund with their premiums and taxpayer
dollars you can still see some of the
mud Ricky Walt and Melissa miles were
trapped in their home for three days
when flooding hit Louisiana in 2016 it
was coming so fast covered in sewer
water they thought things couldn't get
worse their home was ruined but they had
a flood insurance policy that they were
required to buy worth a hundred and
seventy six thousand dollars the
insurance company was a nightmare man it
was when insurance didn't pay enough to
fix their home they had to come up with
the cash themselves to do it
and so they decided to fight the
National Flood Insurance Program for
low-balling them they are still fighting
for forty thousand dollars
this is ridiculous that I'm paying for
something that I have to fight for run
by FEMA the National Flood Insurance
Program is responsible for all flood
policies in the u.s. insurance premiums
and taxpayer dollars fund the program
about three billion dollars a year but
FEMA doesn't administer all the policies
it outsources to private insurance
companies called write your owns or WY
owes they and all of their agents get
paid out of the same pot of money as
flood victims some years up to tooth
thirds of that pot goes to WY O's and
the attorneys they hired a fight against
flood victims come on buddy
it affects by paying their premiums on
time every year homeowners like Ricky
and Melissa help fund the very lawyers
fighting them in courts how can they
sleep at night do windows what they do
it
walls insurance company hired the
Louisiana law firm of Gerald Nielsen to
fight Ricky and Melissa's claim
Nielsen's firm has been fighting flood
claims on behalf of insurance companies
for over 30 years not without
controversy after superstorm sandy
Congress criticized Nielsen's firm for
how it defended WI OS whose engineers
allegedly altered reports to avoid
paying claims he dealt with sandy
victims like they were the perpetrators
enriching himself at their expense a New
York judge called Nielsen's misconduct
in one sandy case remorseless for
delaying cases at taxpayer expense to
give you an idea of the costs involved
here you could rent this 1965 Bentley
Silver Cloud for just under a thousand
dollars for the afternoon
Nielsen's office spent five times that
to ship documents to this law office
from one that is half a mile away CBS
News obtained a budget drafted in 2014
for a sandy case showing Nielsen's firm
estimated that a single case would cost
a hundred and eighty eight thousand
taxpayer dollars if it went to trial the
cap on any home flood policy is two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars mr.
Nelson we're with CBS News Nielson
didn't want to talk to us about his fees
and expenses
some of what you've asked clearly is
privileged a public information request
revealed FEMA paid Nielsen's firm at
least 29 million dollars for Sandy cases
alone things need to change yeah
somebody needs to do something about it
how are you wall hired attorney John Ho
tailing hotelling's firm represents
flood victims and fought in court
against Nielsen's firm during sandy
there was no effort to mitigate the cost
in many cases we were asked to have
experts re-inspect for a third time
homes that were totally destroyed FEMA
says it has no authority to fire lawyers
hired by private insurance companies
they're jacking around policyholders
that's unacceptable and somebody's got
to do something about it and by god it's
supposed to be family Senator John
Kennedy has a bill to change that once
they get that authority I won't chase
them like a hound from hell until I
found out find out that they fix this
problem because I believe there is a
problem homeowners like Wahl wish FEMA
had tightened its belt before making him
pay out of his own pockets
that's not fair and they say that's
American Way that's not fair Gerald
Nielsen the lawyer who defends wyo said
in a letter to CBS News he could not
talk about his fees and expenses but
that he was acting at the direction of
his clients and that all of his firm's
bills were reviewed by clients and FEMA
FEMA did respond to our report overnight
saying it will pay every dime
policyholders are due and it's created
an oversight team to address billing and
other litigation matters
do you have thanks of course the
question of what's do is is the one at
issue 30 million dollars 30 million
dollars or one lawyer trying to keep in
my mean there's a peace of mind and
knowing that you pay your insurance
premiums on time and you think that if
something happens that you're gonna be
reimbursed and everything will be okay
in many cases it's not it's right when
people talk about draining the swamp in
Washington this is what they're talking
about